hello everyone welcome back this is the
fifth screencast in our series on
Advanced behavioral testing for nlu what
we've done so far in the unit is reflect
on the nature of Behavioral testing and
think about its motivations and we've
tried to come to grips with its
strengths and its weaknesses
with that context in place I thought it
would be good to look at some recent
prominent cases of adversarial tests to
see what lessons they can teach us
especially taking a kind of historical
perspective because we've learned a
bunch of things about the nature of
these challenges
let's begin with squad on this slide
here I have some screenshots from the
squad leaderboard that I took recently
the squad leaderboard is nice and
friendly to humans because it gives us
this privileged place at the top of the
leaderboard you can see that humans are
getting around 87 percent exact match so
87 percent accuracy on Squad
but be careful here you actually have to
travel all the way down to position 31
on the leaderboard to find a system that
is worse than humans according to this
metric and many of the systems that are
above humans are well above humans
according to this metric on Squad
so you can essentially picture the
headlines computers have gotten better
at humans than answering questions and
the underlying evidence is Squad and I
think that's the kind of headline that
motivated this first and very prominent
adversarial test from Gia and Liang
2017. this is a an important initial
entry into this modern era of
adversarial testing in nlu
to start let me just remind you of what
the squad task is like we're given
context passages for evidence a question
is posed and the task is to find an
answer to that question and we have
essentially a guarantee that that answer
will be a substring of the context
Passage
Jia and Liang had the intuition that
models might be over fit to the
particular data that was in Squad and so
they set up some adversaries to try to
diagnose that problem and the way their
adversaries worked is that they would
append misleading sentences to the ends
of these passages so in this case I've
appended quarterback Leland Stanford
head jersey number 37 in champo 34.
and what Jian Liang find is that with
these appended sentences in place model
switch and start to answer Leland
Stanford they're distracted by this new
and false evidence
so that's worrisome but you might have
an intuition that we can surely overcome
this adversary what we should do is take
this augmented train set with these
appended sentences on it and retrain our
models and then surely the models will
overcome this adversary and indeed we
find that they do overcome this
particular adversary and they will stop
being misled by the appended sentence
but giann Leong are ahead of you what
about an adversary where we simply
pre-pend these misleading sentences to
the evidence passages they find again
that models are distracted and start to
answer Leland Stanford using that first
new sentence
then you could think well we can now
train on the augmented train set that
has the pre-pending and the upending and
maybe now we'll have overcome the
adversary but you can see what kind of
dynamic we've set up now we could put
the misleading sentences in the middle
of the passage and again we'd probably
see models start to fall down
and fall down they did here is a kind of
leaderboard showing original system
performance for what at the time were
top performing systems for Squad as well
as their performance on this adversary
that Jian Liang had set up
obviously there's an enormous drop in
overall system performance for this
adversary and that is worrisome enough
but I think we should look even more
closely it's noteworthy that the
original ranking has gotten essentially
totally shuffled on this adversarial
leaderboard the original number one
system has fallen to position five the
original two position went all the way
to 10 3 to 12. I think the original
Seventh Place position is now in the
number one slot on the adversary but the
point is that there's essentially no
relationship between original and
adversary this is a plot that kind of
substantiates that I have original
system performance along the x-axis
adversarial along the y-axis and it's
just a cloud of dots showing no evident
correlation between the two
so this probably suggests that systems
were kind of overfit to the original
Squad problem and they're dealing with
this adversary in pretty chaotic ways
and that itself is worrisome I should
say that I'm not sure for this
particular adversary of the current
state of things uh I would love to have
evidence for you about more modern
Transformer systems and how they behave
with these adversaries but as far as I
know no one has done that systematic
testing I think it would be valuable to
have those data points
let's move to a second example this is
natural language inference what I've got
on the slide here is a picture of
performance on snli one of the major
benchmarks for this task over time so
along the x-axis I have time along the
y-axis I have the F1 score and the red
line marks our estimate of human
performance and the blue line is
tracking different systems that are from
the published literature I think it's
important to emphasize that these are
essentially all published papers
what you see is a very rapid progress
over time eventually surpassing our
evidence of human performance and the
line is kind of almost monotonically
increasing which strongly suggests to me
that published papers are learning
implicit lessons from earlier papers
about how to do well on the snli task
but the point is we do now have systems
that are superhuman those are published
papers the multi-nli leaderboard is a
little bit different this is hosted on
kaggle anyone can enter and as a result
you get many more systems competing on
this leaderboard and you get much less
of that kind of community-wide hill
climbing on the task because people who
aren't communicating with each other are
simply entering systems to see how they
did so the blue line oscillates all over
the place but it's still a story of
progress toward that estimate of human
performance
and if you took these numbers at face
value you might conclude that we are
developing systems that are really
really good at doing inference in
natural language at doing what is in
effect Common Sense reasoning
but again the intuition behind
adversaries is that we might worry about
that and one of the first and most
influential entries into the advert
adversarial space for nli was glockner
at all 2018. this is the breaking nli
paper and what they did is conceptually
very simple and draws really nicely on
intuitions around systematicity and
compositionality
I've got two examples on the table here
the first one is going to play on
synonyms so the original premise from
snli is a little girl kneeling in the
dirt crying and that entails a little
girl is very sad
what they did for their adversary is
simply change sad to unhappy
those are synonyms essentially and so we
have an expectation that systems will
continue to say entails in this case
but what glockner at all observed is
that even the best systems are apt to
start switching to calling this a
contradiction case and they do that
because they're kind of overfit to
assuming that the presence of negation
is an indicator for contradiction
and again I love this test because it's
clearly drawing on intuition around
systematicity we assume that
substitution of synonyms should preserve
the snli label and systems are just not
obeying that kind of underlying
principle
the second example is sort of similar
the premise is an elderly couple are
sitting outside a restaurant enjoying
wine the original snli case is a couple
drinking wine and that had the
entailment label for breaking an ally
they switched wine to Champaign now we
have two terms that are kind of siblings
in the conceptual hierarchy they're
disjoint from each other but they're
very semantically related the human
intuition is that these examples are now
neutral because wine and champagne are
disjoint but systems have only a very
fuzzy understanding of that kind of
lexical nuance and so they are very
prone to saying entails for this case as
well again an intuition about the
systematicity of the Lexicon and how it
will play into our judgments about
natural language inference and we're
just not seeing human-like behavior from
these systems
here is the results table from the
glockner at all paper we should exempt
the final lines I think on the grounds
that those systems consumed wordnet
which was the resource that was used to
create the adversary and look at the
systems that are in the top three rows
what you find is that they do really
well on snli's test set right they're in
the mid 80s and they do abysmally on the
new test set are huge Deltas in
performance there
so that's interesting and worrisome but
we should pause here let's look more
carefully at this table in particular at
the model column
all of these models are from the
pre-transformer era
in fact they're just on the cusp of the
Transformer era and these are all
instances of kind of recurrent neural
networks with tons of attention
mechanisms added onto them almost
reaching the insight about how we should
go forward with attention being the the
primary mechanism and you see their kind
of historical period reflected also in
the snli test results which are lower
than systems we routinely train today
built on the Transformer architecture
so we should ask ourselves what will
happen if we test some of these newer
Transformer models so I decided to do
that I simply downloaded a Roberta model
that was fine-tuned on the multi-nli
data set so different from snli which
was used by glockner at all to create
their data set this is the code for
doing it it's a little bit fiddly so I
decided to reproduce it and the headline
here
is that this model off the shelf
essentially solves the glockner at all
adversary we should look just at
contradiction and entailment because
neutral is too small a category in this
little challenge set and you see
impressively high F1 scores
dramatically different from the results
that glockner at all reported from the
pre-transformer era and remember this is
even under domain shift because this
Roberta model was trained on multi-nli
and we're testing it on examples derived
from snli so that looks like a real
success story an adversary that has
essentially been overcome and I think
even the most cynical Among Us would
regard that as a an instance of progress
let's look at a second nli case this one
will play out somewhat differently but
again there are some important Lessons
Learned this is from Nike at all 2018.
it's a larger adversarial test Benchmark
it's got a bunch of different categories
antonyms numerical word overlap negation
and I think a few others
for some of them we're doing something
very similar to glockner which is
drawing on underlying intuitions about
compositionality or systematicity for
doing things like love hate or this
reasoning around numerical terms
but the data set also includes some
things that look more directly
adversarial to me as when we append some
sort of redundant or confusing elements
onto the end of the examples to see
whether that affects system performance
that's more of a kind of squad adversary
intuition I would say
so that's the Benchmark it's pretty
substantial there are lots of examples
in it and the results tell a similar
story we have systems that are pretty
good at multi-nli
but really really bad at essentially all
of the splits from this adversarial
benchmark
but we've seen this data set before we
talked about it when we talked about
inoculation by fine tuning from the
inoculation by five to fine-tuning paper
five of the six panels in this central
figure are actually from this Nike at
all Benchmark and they tell very
different stories we saw that word
overlap and negation were diagnosed as a
data set weakness instance where models
had no problem solving those tasks if
given enough relevant evidence
spelling errors and length mismatch by
contrast were Model weaknesses models
really couldn't get traction on those so
those might still worry us
and numerical reasoning is an example of
a data set artifact where there's
something about the examples that really
disrupts the performance of otherwise
pretty solid models
so three very different lessons coming
from the same challenge or adversarial
Benchmark and I think that's also a sign
of progress because we now have the
tooling to help us go one layer deeper
in terms of understanding why models
might be failing on different of these
challenge test sets which is after all
the kind of analytic Insight that we set
out to achieve with this new mode of
Behavioral testing